Speaker 1: 206 marines have been discharged
for refusing the COVID vaccine.
Now you might say a away, but David, don't
they get the hep a vaccine and the happy vaccine
and the flu vaccine and the MMR vaccine and
the meningococcal vaccine and the polio virus
vaccine and the tetanus diphtheria vaccine
and the varicella vaccine?
And depending on where they're deployed, the
anthrax vaccine and the Haemophilus influenza
type B vaccine and the Japanese encephalitis
vaccine and the pneumococcal vaccine and the
rabies, smallpox, typhoid, yellow fever.
OK.
All right.
Yes, they do.
But this is different.
This is about their rights.
All right.
So the bottom line is every time we hear they're
going to lose a third of the service.
NYPD one third are saying 34 New York Police
Department officers actually discharged, actually
discharged.
And so when I read more than 200 marines removed
for defying COVID mandate, I think this seems
like a good thing.
What I mean by that is when we found out at
the end of the day, 34 NYPD officers were
removed for not getting the vaccine.
I don't know that those are the good apples
that we actually want in NYPD anyway.
And much the same way, if these are the two
hundred and six that are being removed, there's
something like 18000 marines or something.
No, I'm sorry, 180000 Marines.
This represents 0.11 percent of them.
I think this is fine.
These don't sound like team player.
Marines report from Axios U.S. Marine Corps
said it removed two hundred and six service
members for refusing the vaccine.
Updated numbers come as DOD has ramped up
repercussions for those defying the vaccine
order.
The branch said it had already discharged
103.
The big picture Approximately 94 percent of
active members are fully vaccinated.
As of last week, roughly 98 percent of all
active duty forces, including reserves, have
received the vaccine.
Remember that Defense Secretary Lloyd Austin
in August said all troops must get the vaccine,
encouraged service leaders to set up their
own timelines.
To date, approximately 3847 requests for religious
accommodation over the vaccine have been made.
Zero have been approved, according to a Marine
Corps communication officer.
One note about that.
This doesn't mean everyone else is vaccinated.
Some of those requests, although they haven't
been approved for an exemption, they may still
be in process.
So that's where you get.
That's why we're still short of 100 percent.
There are people who have made a request for
an exemption.
It has not yet been adjudicated or even if
it has, it has not yet led to a discharge.
And so that's all going to have to sort of
be be sorted out.
Service members can request to opt out of
mandatory health elements on the base of vaccination
on the basis of a health situation, an administrative
reason.
I don't know exactly what would count as that
or a religious exemption.
Those can be temporarily granted or permanently
granted.
So far from what we're seeing, none of them
have been granted for marines.
I read a comment and I don't I don't know.
I mean, this is it's just a comment from one
member of the U.S. Navy that there are service
members who are looking for a way out and
that refusing a vaccine is a way to get an
honorable discharge.
Maybe benefits, maybe benefits.
Although we're hearing conflicting things
about benefits and that this is a way for
some people who are looking to leave anyway
to do it while saving face.
That's one opinion from one member of the
U.S. Navy who wrote to me.
Take it for what it is, which is which is
simply an anecdote.
But the the big takeaway continues to be the
legality of these requirements is not in question.
The morality can be argued.
The effectiveness is also not in question.
These work and, you know, United Airlines
was a big one where much hubbub was made and
like everybody got vaccinated other than I
think it was 200 people or something like
that.
So these requirements do work.
There's a fair debate to be had about in the
context of Comic-Con, where there is only
some protection, some protection from two
doses against getting an asymptomatic infection.
What is really the goal here?
Well, the primary goal seems to be to keep
the burden on hospitals down by preventing
people from ending up hospitalized.
But these next four weeks are going to be
wild.
The numbers are insane that we are seeing,
and maybe by tomorrow, maybe by Wednesday,
we'll have kind of like the full catch caught
up numbers from the holiday and then we'll
see how things are looking at that point.